your city and Country
city and state
and we'll be starting in just about two
minutes
all right
from the United Arab Emirates
welcome
Australia
India of course Nigeria
plugs in the Philippines and Australia
it's a very late at night so I'm really
uh honored that you're here
Indonesia as well
Bangladesh
thank you
London Ghana
Canada India
say North America Europe Australia
Asia and Africa that's five
of the continents
number of folks from India
right we'll be starting in just about 10
seconds here
Mexico
Morocco Italy
Bucharest welcome
you're on
Ethiopia
Botswana wow
all right I'm going to switch over the
chat so that you can just ask
questions to me
and we will get the session started now
if you do have questions for the Q a
later please put them into the Q a
function within Zoom
here we go
so
let me double check that we are
recording
yep
and I want to welcome everyone to
the
strategies for building effective
leadership skills session here we'll be
talking about a program from MIT X pro
which is their extended education
program
and I'm Stuart Creek from Simply learn
we're the delivery partner for mitx Pro
for this and another program
we'll talk about uh today a little bit
about you I'll be asking you a few
questions in polls so watch out for
those we'll talk about the impact of
leadership skills
and why they are so vitally important to
the success of businesses organizations
into your success
we'll talk about how this program works
learner outcomes and we'll go over the
enrollment process and a bonus offer for
being here
with me today so I appreciate your being
here and we're going to give you a
offer at the end of the session
let's start off with
how many years of experience you have
this is the first of the polls I
mentioned
sure we get the right one
just leave this open for about 15
seconds
curious to know who's in our audience
today
and I will close the poll in five four
three
two one
in the poll
and I'll share the result with you
um
only about a quarter of our audience are
folks who are still
in school and the rest of you have
experience in this audience today
heavily weights towards
more experience
five or more years
so
glad that you could join us
let's talk just a little bit about the
impact of leadership skills
leadership is a force multiplier
leadership is how one individual
and get the work of many people done by
organizing that work and directing it
and
motivating people to to match your
objectives and your organization's
strategy
so it's the set of skills that enable
you to accomplish your objectives in
concert with others
leadership is not necessarily
doing as much as it is leading and
that's
sounds like a tautology but it's
something that sometimes leaders forget
that they need to
motivate and inspire
as much as show technical or capability
of their own you need to be able to
influence people
to follow you when you don't have
the authority to command them to
sometimes we're called upon
to take leadership positions in teams
where technically everyone else on the
team is our peer
they may not regard Us in having the
authority to tell them what to do
but it's an incumbent on us the exercise
leadership skills to influence them to
do what the organization needs them to
do
and
we talk about problem-led leadership
which is leadership by solving problems
and that brings the resources of the
organization both
human resources in physical or monetary
resources to bear on problems in an
effective way so you have to be able to
find Solutions and execute them
effectively
so leadership is really the the
art of getting things done
through the actions of others
you need a range of leadership
capabilities and
in this program there's an emphasis on
problem solving
inspiring
your team to join you in the challenge
of solving problems that face your
organization there's the issue of change
management and being able to
direct and influence the direction of
change in your organization as the
environment around you changes as the
resources in your organization change as
priorities and strategies change so it's
very important to be agile and to be
able to understand how to
help the organization pivot as these
circumstances change you need to be
aware of your own inventory of strengths
and capabilities
your own skills
and on what you're capable of so that
you can apply
your skills in the most effective way
using the tools that you're best at
you need to have technical leadership so
we'll discuss this program focuses on
leadership in the context of science
engineering and business so you need to
be able to demonstrate not necessarily
that you can do everyone else's job
better than they can but that you
understand what it is they do and you
intelligently
monitor what it is they do so that you
can direct the overall progress of the
organization towards solving the problem
you need to be able to to ask somebody
what have you accomplished and be able
to understand and
accept that answer
I need to understand strategic alignment
what you do in your team with your group
has to align to the organization's
overall strategy you want to solve
problems that actually move the
organization forward in its strategy and
not go off on tangents that may be
interesting to you and your team but do
not support the strategy of the
organization
you need of course negotiation skills
conflict management skills
because in every team there will be
conflict and in every situation you will
need to
find ways to negotiate and compromise
so that
you may find new ways of solving the
problem that don't fit the original plan
but which lead to success
and you need culture management to be
able to understand how your team fits
into the organization's culture and you
need to be able to project the
organization's culture into your team
so that they can operate effectively
within that environment
as you can appreciate this is a
multi-factored area it goes beyond
what you might consider your job if
you're an engineer if you're a scientist
if you're responsible for a business
area like sales or marketing or
operations
but this really is how you can
accomplish your job more effectively
let's hear from the folks at MIT about
this program
[Music]
leadership is about going to a
destination that others haven't been to
yet an engineering leadership is
fundamentally about changing the
perspective on a problem technology is
the driver of change in organizations
and it's the role of Technology
leadership to anticipate where is that
point of reflection and what new
Direction might we go to continue our
progress
leadership does not have to be the
top-down ego driven way of leading
problem that leadership is about taking
on huge challenges in the world and so
people bring their expertise in as
necessary because this is important work
to do
leadership skills are teachable I'm
convinced that you can train the
techniques and you can train the mindset
let's talk for a second about the
elements of successful leadership if you
don't have influence there's still ways
of persuading people you have to be able
to navigate the three lenses on leading
change
you need to understand who you are and
what you do and do not bring to the
table because as a leader what you want
to do is build a team that complements
the skills that you have leaders are not
in the boardrooms but leaders are in the
field bringing that change and making it
viable and meaningful
engineering leadership today is probably
more than any time in our history what
companies need
and every human being in my view is
designed to be a leader we need to train
to unleash and channel that
[Music]
thank you
all right and
that was a little bit about
the program just a teaser
and we'll be talking more about it in
just a minute but I would like to know
since you are all here
to learn about
leadership and how to develop your
leadership skills what has stopped you
up until now
from finding a program that
would
help you get qualified and certified in
leadership
why haven't you enrolled in some other
program by this time
I'll leave this open for just another 10
seconds or so you can put in one two
three or all four of the
reasons
and I'm going to close the poll in about
five seconds
get your answers in hit that submit
button and we'll close in three
two one
and
so our result shows that the two main
reasons are finding a program that has a
comprehensive curriculum that will cover
you know the full range of skills that I
spoke about previously
and also uh right after that finding
time in your schedule a program that
will let you fit it into your work
schedule as a working professional
um and the third concern is finding a
program that gives you practical
examples of
exercising leadership skills so
with that in mind
talk about this program this is a four
month
program the executive leadership
principles program it is
targeted at engineer scientists and
researchers as you saw in the video and
it is a comprehensive curriculum
designed by MIT to meet the needs of
Industry helping people get
leadership skills that will enable them
to be more effective in those roles it
includes integrated case studies and
online live virtual classrooms so this
is not a program where you sign up to
watch videos
is a program where you sign up to hear
lectures and interact with the lecturers
in a live online virtual classroom
environment
um you'll also be given case studies to
go through and to work through on your
own so that you can come up with how you
would apply your particular skills uh to
leadership problems
it's flexible to fit your lifestyle
meaning that there are certain scheduled
classes to take but then other than that
you will be working on your own time
anytime 24x7 because the platform allows
you to log in at any time that you have
time to to do the work
so all those resources are available to
you if you miss a class you can see a
class recording to catch up on it
at your leisure so this offers you the
flexibility to fit into your working
life the end of the process you get a
certificate from MIT
X pro program and it will certify that
you have completed the program to their
satisfaction again this is an MIT X pro
program we're a delivery partner
but the program is designed by
MIT X pro and managed by them you
receive five continuing education units
from MIT X pro if you are in the field
what requires you to prove that you need
that you've conducted continuing
education and kept your skills up
sometimes that's required by licensing
bodies sometimes by your employer so if
you're in that situation you will get
five continuing education units that's
the standardized unit
for continuing education
proof and then the online master classes
of course this thing delivered by MIT
faculty but also by people from industry
who will bring their industry
perspectives
saw a couple of the names in the video
um you'll connect with an International
Community of professionals because as we
have seen uh leading into today's
session you're here from all over the
world this program is available to
people from all over the world and
you'll be interacting with Learners from
all over the world as well as very
diverse faculty of
MIT
uh speaking of MIT it is a 160 year old
Institution
is one of the
densest concentrations of brilliant
people in the world
it is
uh well-regarded worldwide in it's a
center for the development of technology
and Technical Solutions in a number of
different fields
and of course it's generated a number of
Nobel Prize winners for the research
they did at MIT
or
graduating from MIT and moving on to
research elsewhere people who've won the
touring award in Computing MacArthur
fellows it's commonly known as The
Genius Grant that's awarded the
MacArthur Foundation to people who are
just exceptionally
a bright and interesting gives them an
opportunity to spend some time working
on whatever interests them so MIT is
also the home of a number of different
research centers
so
National and international centers for
research in Computing in Engineering in
artificial intelligence
and having the name MIT on your
resume on your CV
really a feather in your cap it's really
something that will get noticed and will
impress people
we think that this is
really a unique opportunity to learn
from some of the best and brightest
Minds in the world
we talk about who should enroll
program doesn't have necessarily
prerequisites per se
but it is designed for people who are in
engineering science and research either
early to mid-career
are interested in getting some
leadership capabilities people who are
entering into managerial leadership
positions and want to develop those
skills more deeply more strongly
um and people who are
maybe individual contributors team
leaders who want to make a bigger
contribution
by Leading the team
so this is a
the kind of profile that we're looking
for for people who want to enroll
let's talk about how the program
prepares you
you had a question about somebody in the
chat mentioned I'm not sure if the
company will cover the cost and we'll
talk about that in a bit
um
this program
is four courses over the space of the
four months
so the first course is understanding
organizational strategy and capabilities
then negotiating and applying influence
and Power
navigating and leveraging culture and
networks so the third course and the
fourth course is discovering and
implementing your leadership strengths
focusing on the areas that we talked
about before
course one four weeks understanding what
it is on your organizations talks to you
about strategy about product plans about
a product development
um and then the principles of capability
work and dynamic work design and how to
organize work
on problem solving and projects in a way
that is most effective
most agile
negotiation influence and Power
really focus on the idea that
power something you can apply directly
power is your organization has given you
responsibility everyone who works for
you or with you on your team understands
that you wield that Authority
and you can direct them how do you use
that power well that's the third week of
this course and the reason is because
you need to understand the softer
skills in order to be able to understand
the appropriate use of direct power so
week one is negotiation how to work with
people to come up with
Solutions when what you want is not
completely aligned with what they want
be able to come up with a solution that
uh our approach that is mutually
acceptable influence is being able to
use other things besides Authority
in order to get people
aligned to and working on what it is you
want to do so
influence and motivate people without
using direct power and then finally
looking at proper use of direct power so
that your team remains motivated
effective and dynamic
navigating and leveraging culture
networks is the third month of the
program and the culture of your
organization is a set of shared values
it's important that you understand how
to keep your team within that boundary
of shared values so that what you do
harmonize us with what everything else
happens in the organization
networks and understanding where your
team fits within the organization where
to go for support
who's going to be using the products of
your team's work
um all of that is extremely important to
understand
and it's not always
clear simply from an org chart
um it finally change management
week three there will be a simulation of
how to
implement
influence a change of culture within an
organization a situation where
circumstances change and based on the
organization's culture and the networks
that exist there you have to
show how you would
navigate that change and get to the
other side
with effective
efficient leadership
course four
is the one where you look Inward and
become
aware of your inventory of skills
strengths that you bring the weaknesses
you might have places where you need to
recruit or turn to mentors or other
resources so that your team has those
strengths even if you don't
and then finally being able to apply
that set of strengths and skills to
implement your vision through the action
of your team so this is really one of
the more exciting aspects of the program
and one of the most challenging
so
this is under the direction of and is
delivered by
a wide range
of folks from MIT
and you can see that they come from the
engineering department they come from
the School of Management
people in even in urban planning and
Environmental Studies so people who are
looking at broader
societal concerns and how your work will
fit into those that's the important part
of culture and of networks and of
organizational strategy
even more so today than ever before
because organizations do
kind of
look to those externalities and trying
to to incorporate them into their
organizational goals culture and values
so you've got Professor quality from
engineering and Aeronautics astronautics
you have Professor Nina from uh the
engineering program the engineering
leadership program I should say
Professor repenning from
School of Management uh Mr suskin from
Urban environmental planning Professor
mannon from organization studies and
Professor Reagan's from
the School of Management
and
they will call on they will be
delivering classes in the program but
they'll also be calling on
people from outside who will come in
bring industry perspectives
great
lineup of
instructors and resources for you
here are some people who have gone
through the program and we have some of
these on the website I will be sharing
with you the
um web link
a little bit but Lisa
spoke about the value of the case
studies and how they contribute to her
work at the Boeing
Emily speaks about
the value of developing leadership
skills through this program within her
work at Boeing and then
Boeing UK
apologize for this role for Boeing but
um
he Edward talks about the role play
aspects and how case studies in the work
in the classes and
case studies allow you to get a
practical experience of what leadership
skills are and how you apply them in
situations that are drawn from real life
and real industry
the
we hope to to add you to
this roster of people who have
testimonials for this program
at which point I'm going to ask
are you interested based on what you've
heard so far
in enrolling in this program
we'll leave this open just for about 10
seconds it's a yes or no question
I'll close this in five
or three
two
one
hit submit please
and
about 85 percent of you said you are
interested this is an opportune time for
me to share with you
before we get to the Q a
to share with you how to get enrolled
and
cost of the program as well
the enrollment process is very
straightforward again as the delivery
partner you email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
I will put that
into the chat
and
we will review your uh application
ask you some questions about your work
and
your interest and aptitude for
leadership
and
then we'll offer you the
enrollment if you qualify
receive an enrollment offer from our
learning Consultants
the next cohort you can start is uh
classes in July with an induction set
toward the end of June deduction
sessions were straightforward takes
excuse me it'll uh off of Zoom for a
second I'll be right back hold on
Zoom does this occasionally
the induction session is 20 June it's a
very short
again I apologize for that that's a
glitch that sometimes happens
as I was saying the 20th June session is
very short it's a couple of hours that
tell you about how to get navigate the
online platform what to expect from your
curriculum
um and then the classes
normally start July 12th and run for
four months
we say limited seats are available
because in order to be able to give
sufficient attention
to the participants necessary to limit
the size of the cohorts so we usually
cut those off at about 25 to 30 people
per cohort
and so we recommend that if you're
interested you get involved quickly
email us right away
and the program fees are three thousand
two hundred and forty nine dollars in
the US
Emi financing available at 286 dollars a
month
um if you are curious about pricing in
your local area in your country
you can check that on the website and I
will be sharing that link with you
momentarily or you can ask the folks
that ask us at simply learn.net and
they'll be able to share with you what
the pricing is and what currency for
your location
the bonus offer for attending this
webinar is a 10 discount off of the
program feeds
so
taking 10 off if you're in the US North
America taking 10 off of this 3249
dollar fee or if you're in another
location uh 10 off whatever the pricing
is in your location uh question that I
mentioned talked about tuition
reimbursement and whether your employer
will cover the cost of the program for
you that is of course something that
between you and your employer if it's a
benefit or a program that your employer
has through Learning and Development or
through human resources and you would
ask that of your employer
but the number of companies do actually
help with the cost of programs like this
for continuing education so again reach
out to us at ask us at simplylearn.net
and we'll be able to answer questions
about pricing financing and that type of
thing help you get enrolled
so for those of you who said you are
interested
curious to know if you are interested in
getting involved in the
July classes or sometime after that
open for a bit
we're going to leave this open for just
another five seconds
four three
two
one
okay
and
a couple of people who are interested in
getting involved in the July sessions
but uh
quite a few more who are interested
in probably the August or September
sessions that come after that so
if you're looking further down the road
I also recommend that you email us
if you posted on future cohorts as well
this is where we'll go to questions and
answers
I will try to take
questions both from the
q a and from the chat start with the Q a
we had a question for you about from you
about today's session which will be over
uh we're at 902 should be uh about
another 15 to 20 minutes depending on
how many questions we have here
and will you get a certificate for
today's session we will be following up
with an email with the link to this
recording for everyone and also
um
digital proof of attendance certificate
for being here today
um is this course accredited
this course is offered by MIT X pro so
MIT is the body that provides
essentially the
reputation and
credit behind this program and so
the certificate will enable you to claim
that you've completed the program
successfully and if anyone asks MIT will
verify that
this is not a degree program so it's not
subject to the same type of
accreditation in the degree program
might be
look into the chat for some questions
here
any pdus for this session no
not for this
webinar that we're doing right now
common examples of techniques used in
the program
so you covered a little bit of that in
the video but you can
see some more of that at the website
um
and
looking through
do we have other questions please put
those in if you have them into the Q a
I'll check those
how many years of experience should one
have for this program this program
doesn't require that you have experience
however
um this program is really intended for
people who are working in the field of
engineering science or research
and so having some experience will give
you an idea of how
the work is done in those fields and how
the teams are organized so that you'll
understand the role of leadership within
those programs and so that you'll be
able to apply what you learn into
this um
to your work directly
is there a preview available
for this program
um
we don't have a preview per se currently
but We'll advise you when we schedule
something of that nature
um
so unable to pay in installments yes
so
there is Emi financing equal monthly
installment financing and as I showed in
the pricing Slide the monthly payment
for this program is about 286 dollars
if you're
in the US or North America
and you'll be able to ask learning
Consultants about
Emi financing for other regions
uh
how is this different from a
conventional executive Management
program
so that's a an interesting question in
the difference here is that this is
focused
on
the leadership principles for
engineering science and
research so this is for people who are
in technical environments where maybe
they have been focused on
uh knowing their field and doing great
technical work
and now they're you're being called on
you know if you've if you've been
focused on
writing great code or doing great work
in the laboratory or coming up with
um interesting youth theories
and now you're being asked to lead your
team
or take a more responsible role
uh it may be a difficult transition for
you if you haven't got
exposure to the skills experience with
the skills and that's what this program
provides you so it's focused not on
necessarily the
executive management skills might focus
on sales and marketing that might focus
on financial management
my focus on
supply chain and operations
this is a program that focuses on
leadership of teams that are designed to
solve interesting problems and so that's
the focus of this program and why it's
Unique and different from the general
Management program
are there discounts available for
students outside of developed world and
you would ask that of the folks that ask
us at simplylearn.net
um
I'm going to look into q a one more time
to see if there's any questions there I
hadn't yet
and any chance for full scholarship
again please ask the folks that
ask us at simplylearn.com
I have someone's uh a piece of someone's
resume here I'm not going to comment on
that but uh
this is something that you can uh
discuss with the people at ask us at
simplylearn.net about your background
for uh
getting into the
program
and
can one Aspire the final question can
one aspire to go for leadership posts
without
uh prior leadership duties but having
skills for knowledge and already
performing in other roles so
if you think about that that is actually
the only way to get into a leadership
position
because every leader starts off not
being a leader every leader starts off
with
uh
moving into a leadership role from some
other position so uh
necessary to develop the skills of
leadership in order to move into a
leadership role and you can develop
experience in leadership by Leading
smaller groups be situationally being a
project leader
I'm becoming a team leader
and and then moving up to the leader of
a group a department
and
up in Chain of management if that's the
direction you want to go this program
focuses not only on developing a
management
chain of career path but also
understanding leadership to be more
effective in the technical role so you
may not want to move out of your
technical role you may not want to move
out of
participating directly in the work that
you do with your peers but this will
allow you to be the leader of your group
of your team
in a more effective way
so
that I'm going to close the Q and A
and
of one last question for our audience
before we finish
hopefully Zoom will not toss me back out
again
last poll question uh do you want us to
reach out to you
to
with enrollment
but it will kick me off for just a
second I'll be right back
it's a transition thing with zoom
so
foreign
if you answer yes to this question we
will
have one of our learning Consultants
contact you directly
and I'll end up pulling five four three
two one okay
so about forty percent of you said yes
we will as I said uh reach out to you
directly
and
help you get started in the program
answer any questions you have
with that I want to thank you all for
being here
I appreciate
your willingness especially for those of
you in places like Australia and the
Philippines where it's very very late
or depending on your perspective very
very early in the morning and we're very
honored to have you all here from
wherever you are in the world
thank you we hope we can welcome you
into the Learning Community with MIT X
pro as I promised I'm going to put into
the chat right now
the link that will take you to the
web page for the program
and
which will allow you to
find some more details
or you contact us at ask us at
simplywink Dot
second here